what's up gamers it's gaming time y'all
thought I was scared of a video game
made for children I don't think so I'm
gonna play it again and I'm gonna beat
it and I'm gonna kill it and it's gonna
be easy
alright let's go okay this should be
great I'm already touching my how am I
supposed to donate my finger and not the
long enough why am i finger not long
enough there we go there we go
they are is great guys definitely buy a
VR headset it's working seaming Leslie
that's a word okay okay it works okay
now it works okay it's all cool right
are we still going all right cool okay
all right this is working pretty well
laughs okay so I'm on night three and
this is when the Fox comes and I have to
keep I have to keep my eye on the Fox
start 33rd and that's fine
look how close I am can I drink slurp
slurp
shut up stop calling me I don't care
about the instructions I don't care shut
your piping poopy poopy papa
god damn it and you worthless look how
fast I can change cameras down this is
way better dude look how [ __ ] fast I
am bruh all right where's the jungle
brother Darius all right there they are
I say yo ice up or the chicken [ __ ] go
where's hi sexy mama sleepin there she
is that's my girl that's my girl she's
freaking me with her ice
I can't wait to see her dick okay there
she is
he is help me I am looking at you I'm
looking at you all right where's the
chicken where's my chicken [ __ ] she's
coming she's coming to poppy she knows
what she wants and she wants to get it I
get it but this time I'm not pulling any
strengths I'm not pissing on anyone's
paying hey hey chicken you want to come
to my
house so bad that the bad mr. chicken
you dumb but look at that chicken
alright I'll share forgot about you
alright we gotta be ready we're gonna be
ready I'm ready
as frickin you could ever be alright you
better or not I'm looking at you I'm
looking at you so [ __ ] hard dude
oh the door was closed stupid box go
back to Norway the land that no one stop
everyone stop stop
ticket get a job you piece of crap okay
we're good
everything is good we're not doing too
bad I've been doing a pretty good there
plenty of power left dude we're gonna
have a good name it's gonna be a good
name we're literally where is everyone
I don't see a single soul okay we cannot
do this there is hope in Sweden my
meatball is protection oh that means
someone moved
chicken chicken stop it why did you keep
coming
that's sexy [ __ ] alright okay hey hey
what are you looking at what is he doing
there you're not supposed to who are you
what
it's a coin should I be scared of him
yeah oh god damn it it's him again what
do I do
okay he's still there bunny how her
where is everyone well he didn't even me
I knew he was there it was just to
confirm that he was in fact there god
damn it
where's that you son of a sucker mom I
am touching that thing as soon as my
nipples can you stop I'm so done with
all of this what what is that what does
that mean door is closed
Sorry Sorry nuts open nuts tell you laid
daniele my nail oh thank you
god damn they pissed me off dude I don't
even feel happy all right hey it's my
award what do I get
oh thanks good so there's night for as
well brah
what is its parts and service all right
let's try this for the sake of a change
all right I plead these hi Jason back to
parts and service oh no it looks like
Bonnie's guitar is out of tune and must
be recalibrated okay first we must
access his harmonization module located
inside his secondary three pipe to
access the Turnpike those eyes must
first be removed
they'll be as precise as possible when
removing the eyes from their respective
sockets why all right he's got me left
eye and carefully remove it from its
socket
okay mr. Bundy let me remove the IE
every job deposit the left what that
frickin murky you did nothing but laugh
in the back two parts and service oh no
it looks like Bonnie's guitar is out of
tune and must be recalibrated
first we must accent great job deposit
the left eye in the cleaning receptacle
on your left what the hell is this
Oh left why did he say it dumb game okay
it looks like Bonnie's great job deposit
the long time lag well done now
grip Bonnie's right eye and carefully
remove it from its socket Oh
all right let's actually follow the
instructions this time the babies at the
right eye in the cleaning receptacle on
your right good job yeah each plate
carefully press the two buttons located
on either side of Bonnie's jaw when done
correctly you should hear two small
clicks what do you mean okay let them
breath sing her jab laughs both babies
formalization module press the blinking
button inside Bonnie's secondary throat
pipe to enter calibration mode he's got
the throat pipe okay let me just press
the little button there it is I press
the button okay then that's that if
something is not right one of those
notes is out of tune you may push the
button again to replay the audio check
press the colored button that
corresponds to the incorrect note okay
[Music]
well it's definitely the second one
press the blinking button again to
verify your work okay well I guess he's
playing it what the hell
egg there's no tension I'm just doing it
welcome back to part since all right
great job damn well done now firmly grip
deposit the right eye good job to open
the well done you now have access to
Bonnie's harmonization module press the
blinking bodies something is not right
you can speedrun' back was it the left
eye in the cleaning receptacle on your
left alright this is not the game for me
are you having fun yes that's great to
hear
alright what is this then dark rooms
let's go what is this
[Music]
Knight sir what the hell did I just do
why can't they play it okay here we go
closed doors grab and release with
trigger well what what is this oh my god
this is freaky Hey Oh God
hello okay shut it shut your mouth I'm
trying to play game what is this I'm
closing the doors hey close the door
there we go god dammit who we invent the
door hey listen up you piece of crap I
don't kick Sammy Sosa God you break off
I never play this I don't know the rules
and they just jump in my face a scourge
may ask Alice babe that's a lot who's
doing that you're in the drawer he's in
the drawer let me I can't move I
basically cannot move my hand is lost I
lost my hand
[ __ ] this I want out I'd literally you
freak off I mean so far nothing Bad's
happened
[Music]
I did it I actually did it I can't see
anything alright welcome back to parts
and service great job deposit well done
now firmly grip deposit the right eye if
good job to open Bonnie's faceplate
carefully press well done you now have
access to Bonnie's harmonization module
press the blinking button inside
Bonnie's secondary something is not
right
one of those notes is out of tune if
they may push the button again to replay
the audio check press the colored button
that corresponds to the incorrect note
press the blinking button again to
verify your work don't scare me don't
hey great job bonnie is in tune and
ready for his solo all right close him
up
Sallie replaced both eyes in the same
order that you removed them then close
up the faceplate and we'll call it a day
and we'll call it a day you hear that
Barney boom BAM there you go you can see
now wait he didn't tell me to do
anything else I'm calling it a day all
right I guess I press these well that
concludes your parts and services task
see you next time dude I like your needs
all right cool I did it I did it
[Music]
are these meatballs they actually have
meatballs in the game ah ok let's oh oh
let's see what chica has to offer
welcome back yeah there have been
complaints about chicas acrid smell
sounds like chica has been rummaging
around the kitchen again yo particles
from chicas exterior and place it in the
refuse bin on your right wait what was I
supposed to do take them all right in
your knee you had the one in your knees
not hiding any other treats inside her
beak uh open her beak carefully press
the two buttons located on the sides of
chicas head chica have you been cheating
okay all right here we go
ah see if I'm a backed-up some unwanted
friends to clear the infestation applied
the fazbear entertainment
restaurant-grade Kimmy spray two chicas
exterior press the button under the
avoid inhaling the Kimmy spray Oh who's
your to cleaning disinfecting and
mountainous chemicals may result in
respiratory problems skin or eye
irritation good job now reattach chicas
upper arm hand and cupcake plate what
the hell
this alright there you go
arm hand and cupcake plane hey Gus well
done if you know it looks like chica
needs another dose of the chemi spray I
find not let the infestations friend be
sure to give the canister button another
push as needed return the cupcakes to
chicas plate cupcake return the cupcakes
to chicas please oh my god damnit Eve's
running around cupcakes don't run come
back here you snake loose the cupcake on
the plate I'm trying cupcake I can't
come here please place the cake on the
plate
yeah great job chica is ready to serve
pizza and hugs to the kids again take a
complimentary slice of pizza for a job
well done I take a slice I physically
cannot go back there I don't know oh
thank you don't you eat it delicious
see you next time ah
chica didn't chick with me
I thought me and chica will get a bit
freaka if you know what I mean welcome
back
to parts and service it looks like one
of our guests left a personal item on
our star attraction
let's return it to the lost and found ha
ha ha ha carefully grab and remove the
child's head from Freddy's got a pretty
good hold of it come on Freddy their
firm tug good jobs right Freddy I'll
place the hat in the lost-and-found bin
on your right while we're at it let's
make sure there isn't anything else
stuck inside to access Freddy's chest
cavity grab Freddy's bowtie and pull it
outwards oh that's cute
well done Wow Freddy's chest cavity is
now open remove the child's watch and
place it in the lost-and-found bin be
careful not to touch any of Freddy's
sensitive wiring a table it appears
there is a child's shoe wedged behind
Freddy's music box
the music box must be removed you may
access the child's shoe gently grasp the
music box and extract it from Freddy's
chest cavity before the safety latch
descends what's the music box carefully
place the music box on the work table to
your left great job to reset the safety
latch press the button located on
Freddy's it now remove the child's shoe
and places in the lost-and-found bin oh
[ __ ] I can't reach oh come on I can't
reach my hand god dammit I can't go that
way that's not fair
alright let's do one more
[Music]
I'm ready stop calling me oh god they're
moving everywhere oh you are there too
whose moaning like that
you got to be fast on the door man
oh you snake I'm ready
come then come then you here you can
have a cupcake if you come I ain't
afraid of you
[ __ ] are you kidding me
are you actually kidding me I'm done
hope you guys in joyed five nights at
freddy's this has been an epic gaming
time and smash like subscribe and share
with all your friends and subscribe
especially what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]